well yes I think we fun to talk a little
bit about magic squares and magic
squares have fascinated mathematicians
and artists as well for many hundreds of
years and I'd like to show you just a
print that's called melancholia won by a
German artist and in this you can see a
rather plump melancholy angel with
various mathematical devices she's
holding a pair of compasses in her hand
there's this complex geometrical object
here this is sphere down here and then
various tools and objects and also we
can see a wonderful comment and a
rainbow time is passing and up in the
top-right right-hand corner we have a
magic square and if we zoom in on this
it's written in slightly old-fashioned
symbols but somewhere okay so this is
written out in in modern versions of the
numerals the magic square that appears
in Duras painting of melancholia one and
if you if you look at this you'll see
that all of the rows so this row if you
have those numbers up 16 plus 3 plus 2
plus 13 hours up to 13 434 and if we
look down this column here 13 3 plus 10
plus 6 plus 15 that adds up to 34 and
then if you look along the diagonal if I
remember correctly that's 26 and then
that's also 34 and this diagonal is also
34 and we've got a four by four square
here notice and we've used the first 16
numbers to fill that Square and that's
your typical Magic Square now this one
really fascinates me I've got it hanging
up at home and I was looking at it one
day a couple of weeks ago in fact and I
severed something that I've never seen
before and I've looked around on on
Wikipedia and not not seen any reference
to it but if you add all the numbers in
melancholia so if you add all the
numbers of the Magic Square and we've
seen that each College of the four
columns as 34 so if we take four times
34 we get 100
thirty-six and then if we look for one
more number in melancholia it's called
melancholia one and if I add one to 136
I get 137 and this is approximately he
cooked - what about alpha my friend the
fine-structure constant which tells us
the ratio of the strength of the
electrical force to the quantum how you
suggested is something some some
meaningless no no is purely coincidence
but I think it's purely coincidence but
it's where I think it's very funny and
it's not very widely known so I I'd be
great if we can put it in sixty symbols
and doo-doo-doo words squares yeah I
mean I've been fascinated with these
things since I've been a kid and I
played around seeing if I could make
them and I started off with a nice
simple odd 3 by 3 number squares and I
wanted to try make all the rows and
columns add up and I think this the
rather plump angel here just looks like
a physicist and she's obviously worried
about infinities or or integer numbers
or the volume of this and thinking about
spheres or maybe she's seen this comment
on the rainbow wondering about it
it's just delight to a physicist to see
it so I find them she looks very patient
just thinking where the problems and
that's what we have to do and when we
get a bit melancholic and depressed we
have to press on with our calculations
and do our experiments so I find it just
inspiring